okay guys it's friday again which means
i'm here to tell you about all the most
important things that happen to gaming
this week after five years of waiting
those who were affected by the
playstation network downtime in 2011 are
now being offered compensation
compensation for the infamous PSN hack
is available to those who filed for a
settlement claim which sony began
accepting in january of last year some
of the options you can choose from
include a free ps3 or PSP game 3 free
ps3 themes or a free 3 month
subscription to PlayStation Plus the
compensation stems from a class-action
lawsuit which was brought against Sony
for the PSN breach and ultimately
resulted in a multi-million dollar
settlement if you've been playing the
division you've probably noticed that
other players can block your path
leading to some hilarious but ultimately
annoying results players who have been
physically obstructed by others who
prevent them from moving forward have
been pretty vocal expressing their
frustration however there is a built-in
workaround Ubisoft explained players can
force their way past or through others
by continuously running into said
players for approximately 3 seconds this
will result in you passing through their
character model at which point you can
get back to your mission Microsoft has
these development on fable legends and
is in discussions to close lionhead
studios Microsoft explained there in
discussions to shut this studio which
was founded by peter molyneux in 1996 GM
of microsoft studios europe hello Lemke
said the publisher is working with those
affected and find a new position on top
of that it was announced to that press
play studios who created kalimba and max
the curse of brotherhood will also be
shutting down the beta for fable legends
is currently running and will continue
to do so up until April 13 when the
service will be turned off sony has
admitted their virtual reality offering
may not be as technically capable as
oculus rift Sony Computer Entertainment
VP murcia
to ito talk to polygon about comparing
PlayStation VR to the rift and vibe he
said if you just talk about the high-end
quality yes I would admit that oculus
may have better PR however requires a
very expensive and very fast pc the
biggest advantage for Sony is our
headset works with ps4 it's more for
everyday use so it has to be easy to use
and it has to be affordable this is not
for the person who uses a high-end PC
it's for the mass market PlayStation VR
is scheduled to arrive in the first half
of this year and finally big star wars
the force awakens spoilers lie ahead in
the last Ori of this week so be sure to
switch off now if you don't want to know
what happens JJ Abrams has admitted that
he made a mistake with a choice he made
in the recent blockbuster specifically
the part where ray is given a comforting
hug by layer after something big happens
to hon but Chewbacca doesn't receive the
same sympathy Abrams explained that was
probably one of the mistakes I made had
Chewbacca not been where he was you
probably wouldn't have thought of it not
because he was right there passed by
layer it felt almost like a slight which
was definitely not the intention let me
know down in that comment section what
you cared about this week and which VR
option you're most excited for right now
this week on site we review hitman
episode 1 show off the division in 2k
resolution and take a look at stargell
belly that's everything I love you this
week do be sure to have yourself an
excellent weekend and I will see you
again on Monday